coming up big like he did last year in
new york
[Music]
right well the other hoop for durant
[Music]
coming up on two minutes remaining in
the fourth paul
george again so he has
39 and he is within range of the
all-time record as
leather puts it that way held by will
chamberlain 42 points
cody lots of time lots of room for
stephen for steph he now has
23 points that's his fifth three here is
george
[Applause]
so paul george was 41.
one and that's what westbrook had last
year
just under a minute and a half from deep
durant
brian and durant
[Music]
down to 50 seconds remaining
curry flips it westbrook shoots it
and hits the three curry
puts off the boards for davis
oh why not here anthony davis
of the new orleans pelicans in his
fourth all-star
game averages just under 28 a game
holding the ball but that time he was
looking to pass and couldn't find
anybody he wouldn't want to shoot that
he did
not even off the glass and again it's
davis the mvp voting here tonight 52
points
for the hometown star anthony davis
and derozan lays it home just not able
to hit on the reverse gun
kevin durant has a triple double with
21 points 10 assists 10 rebounds in the
second half he now has 12.
once again similar to last year a host
of
offensive records irving for three
oh with a backhand attempt at it
by davis this looks like the the
practice that we saw
yesterday george uncontested
stuffs star games will this type of play
to take place well not throughout
all 48 minutes once again
[Applause]
embiid is guarding george puts the move
on embiid
what a block oh man what a block by
embiid
the effort by him you are on the island
and you can get embarrassed
he catches up gets back in the play
speed
westbrook putting moves on derozan
by one it's all defense that made this
happen they were challenged they had to
move the ball and go back to basic
basketball with seven remaining
and they have possession westbrook gets
ahead of the field and
he he's to paint lebron finishes the
smart play lebron knowing he's going to
get fouled
passes it up out of five seconds
curry looking for the throw curry double
king
curry can't find it and that will do it
and keem lebron off the bench
[Applause]
well i have to say that this season
the change in foreign lebron defeating
team stephanie what
george for three
[Applause]
i see you uncle drew coming up on a
minute remaining
in the fourth durant oh he's on fire
here on the fourth quarter
oh he's on fire here on the fourth
quarter
[Music]
31 points for durant irving with the
steal
hardy putting lose on curry
to the step back from now
[Applause]
so team lebron will make it
[Music]
[Applause]
that's one for the city of charlotte to
cap
final score team lebron coming from
behind
and they beat tedious 178-164
[Applause]
leonard dumps it down low oh a gorgeous
reverse
by anthony davis and paul come together
and chris paul is upset
tiana's up 150 to 148.
with the pull-off yes
i think harden took a shot to the head
of walker all right here's lebron
setting it up
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Applause]
review that
oh that's good lebron played by walker
[Applause]
spins away but that's okay that's okay
you're still in the game if you're
seeing
it played by giannis captain
guarding one another there's the pass to
davis and
we got a whistle the foul is called so
davis to the line he could win it
uh
[Applause]
wait a minute it's not over yet are you
kidding me
[Music]
[Applause]
of the night anthony davis missed the
first